Một tháng 20,5 năm, hành không trang hệ sảo.
Hà nội dự kiến thì điểm vùng phát thay thấp và cấm sẽ mấy sẵn theo khung dơ bán ngày cuy tòan.
Theo dự thảo tới trên người bán nhân dân thình phó hà nội.
Về điểm vùng phát thay thấp trong bánh này một giá đoạn một thương 1 tháng 20,5.
Thành phố sẽ chuyển khai thì điểm vùng phát thay thấp tại phương hoàn kiếm.
Cụ thế, vùng phát thay thấp dưới hạn trong mùi một tiến phố thuộc phương hoàn kiếm vùng,
trong tiền tháng khai, lưu thay tổ, tháng đào, tháng ngang, tháng buồm, mắm mấy, tháng bạc, tháng mắm,
quyền nếu hình đi thay tổ.
Trong vùng phát thay thấp, xem mấy sẵn bị cấm đưa thông từ 11.2.
Dự đến 20.2.2.
từ 6.2.2.2.
và chuyển nhật.
Sê mô tô sẽ gặn mấy sẵn hạn động kinh ra in trên nền tạng phần mềm ứng dục hỗ trợ kết nối vận tải của bị cấm.
Các loại ưu túi dây hải tấn đáp ứng cuy chuẩn khí thải mất bốn
Chỉ được phát mặt động ngoài dơ cao điểm.
Ô tô tải từ hai tấn đến dưới bác phy năm tấn.
Đáp ứng cuy chuẩn khí thải mất bốn.
Chỉ được phát trải từ hai mốt dờ đến sảo dưới vụm sau,
và phai được công an thành phố chấp thận mạnh hoàn bản.
Ô tô tải trên bạc với năm tấn bị cấm hòa đậu.
Hình phố xác định dài đảng 2 từ ngày 1 tính một năm hành thú trong ngày bẩy.
Đến bà mốt tháng ngày 2 năm hành thú trong ngày bẩy.
Mời giọng cuy vực đá phi điểm tại phẩm hành kiếm và cười năm,
và bùng lỗi phần hành kiếm đã thử dẻ ở gia đận một.
Và mấy bốn tuyên phố báo quanh thuộc phân cười năm,
gia đận 3 từ 1 tính một năm hành thú trong ngày tảng.
Đến bà mốt tháng ngày 2 năm hành thú trong ngày chiến,
thành phố mời giọng vùng phát hệ thấp thận bộ diện tích trong vài năm một.